[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosen bomb hello I hope you're
having a wonderful day uh week thanks
for choosing this podcast to listen to
we usually dive deep today we dive a
little deep and uh I appreciate
everybody tuning in thank you patreon
patreon.com inside you if you want to
support the podcast in awesome other
ways Patron is a is a cool thing where
you some people get boxes from me every
couple months and there's tons of perks
so check it out you get to get your name
shouted out on the podcast etc etc the
handles are Ryan
tez no they're not but you're if you're
asking me to say them I will tell you
that inside of pod on Twitter at inside
OFW podcast on Facebook and Instagram
that is true I'm not calling it X just
by the way yeah I'm not either it's
Twitter it's it's Twitter it's Twitter I
don't care yeah I don't either look at
us standing up to billionaires yeah
we're standing up [__] them um yeah it's
been a crazy uh crazy week crazy weekend
I've been traveling a lot and uh hope
you guys are being good to yourself and
you know trying to do some healthy
things and all that stuff therapy and
whatever you do to make yourself feel
better about yourself that's what what
counts um what else um inside of you
online store lots of cool stuff small
small little
stuff um allowed to say that word
probably not
you know there stuff from that show was
I was on tons of merch tumblers whatnot
ship Keys scripts and then the the talk
podcast.com there's new pieces of art of
me and Tom signed I'm on the Cameo you
can get see where I'm going and cons and
all that Instagram at the Michel Rosen
bomb and you just go to link tree there
I am and last but not least the band
sunspin wearing the sunspin hat today
you like the new sunspin hat I like the
color thanks I worked on it they're not
even for sale but I might I might put
them on the um inside of you I like it
it's like an electric blue electric blue
electric blue on mine that was a cool
song sunspin is the band sunspin decom
if you want to book us or you want to uh
see when our concerts are or you want
merch or you want to book us on a zoom
it's there and uh yeah been seeing a lot
of patrons and a lot of people come to
these cons and it's so cool to put faces
and names together and you know what I
have actually gifts for you there's
there's another somebody made another
bracelet of Ryan oh neat and one of
Bryce um yeah folks love you I don't
know why they're like why don't you to
get inside of
Ryan maybe for a patreon episode I think
we should do that why don't we get
inside Ryan for their next patreon yeah
all right I'll just ask you questions
okay and then we can hear your your
Denny's steak story again oh God I told
it again to Joel mcale that's coming out
but uh maybe we'll cut it I don't know I
think Bryce gets a kick out of it but um
anyway today's guest is someone I've
always loved as an actor Peter fanelli
you know I'm from that vampire series of
movies and uh he's been in a lot of
stuff and he's got this new movie coming
out which uh I'm stoked about which
we'll talk about um he's a he's a really
good dude just a solid dude I had no
idea but I think you're G to really
enjoy this one I hope you do and you'll
let me know what you think after so why
don't we just do it Ryan why don't we
get inside of Peter fanelli it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michel Rosen
[Music]
B inside of you with Michael rosenbom
was not recorded in front of a live
studio audience yeah actors are really
funny cuz they're like I just want to
get on a show if I could just get on a
show last like 10 years and then when
they get on the show they're like it's
like prison and it is a little like
going to jail because you're working 12
hours a day yeah and you don't get much
of a life so like people don't realize
like you be careful what you wish for
because when you get on a show like and
you're you're you know one of top one
two or three on the call sheet oh your
life's done that's your life that that
becomes your life like like you get and
on the weekends you're so tired but
you're learning lines for the next week
so like you never really have a
Perpetual stress isn't it you're not I
don't I don't know stress is just like
you don't get to live life because you
your life becomes that character in that
show and then and you have very few
moments for yourself you know what I
mean yeah but don't you think that if
you're constantly learning lines if you
have this responsibility if there's
always a pressure on you to look good to
be rested to perform to do you know it's
like imagine it to me it's like like sex
it's like you you're we have to perform
you know you have to and if it doesn't
work then everybody's disappointed MH
and so there is a stress that I feel
like if you're on a show for 7 10 years
that at least I did I always carry that
I have to be good I have to know my
lines I have to always I'm hanging out
with my friends I'm like oh two days I
film there's pressure PR there's
pressure you know like you're always
thinking like I got to know my lines for
Monday so if you're doing something on
Saturday like you never relax never
really you don't relax till that series
over yeah yeah maybe you maybe you
you're different you seem more laid-back
than I am like you you could deal with
pressure I I haven't done the show I
mean I did a show for seven years but I
wasn't like was it about the opposite of
a doctor there was some doctors and
stuff and and Hospital stuff but um but
I I I wasn't number one on the call
sheet so like I and it was more of an
ensemble and it was a half hour so we
only filmed five day episodes it was
kind of it was really lovely actually it
was perfect because like I went in and I
had uh you know Wonderful actors to work
with uh I really enjoyed working with
them and it was just enough where I had
some days off and like I could fly it
shot in New York so I could fly home on
the
weekends um and see my kids so so it was
a good balance so I could see you know
uh but if you were number one or two I
did do a series I was number one on and
it only went a year
but and we did like 22 Episodes and and
that's a lot cuz 10 months out of the
year you're on set like 12 hours a day
it sounds like oh boohoo us but like
it's it's not glamorous it's not it's
not red carpet it's definitely like I
mean there people taking care of you you
know you're hungry you need a Coke I can
get you a Coke and you know so so it's
not like that's cuz you don't have time
to do it you don't have time to do it
it's it's basically that if you're like
no I'll get my own C no I'll get it no
no no go on set we need you on set yeah
uh but uh yeah but I didn't have to do
that I didn't do that Series in
particular for seven and I and and even
though it would have been nice to get
like one more year out of that like I I
was careful after that to like choose
like I remember getting an offer for uh
a series and it shot it was 22 Episodes
and like uh and it was a straight offer
and it was wonderful cuz when you get a
straight offer right yeah uh and but it
shot in Chicago and I thought okay I had
the same thing yeah and I thought okay
so I have kids and if I take this series
in Chicago I'm not going to see them for
10 months out of the year cuz it's like
I'm number one on the college sh I won't
be able to fly home on the weekends
right and uh and and and they're not
going to come to Chicago because my kids
were all in school in La so then like 10
months out of the year I'm was like I'm
not going to see them and then as an
actor you're like best case scenario
this goes seven years so I won't see my
family for what seven years like like
and then they're going to be grown up
I'll have a ton of money but I I won't
have had the time with them so then it
became like I said no and then they came
back with more money and then I said no
again and then my agent was like no no
take the money and I was like I I can't
because like I they were like it's they
they they were throwing ridiculous the
more you say no that's like an apodan I
know only if you mean it never say no if
you're trying to get something if you're
try to get something it doesn't work you
have to really like they smell it out
you know yeah like I don't want to do it
yeah well what's going to cost us yeah
nothing yeah and then and then it came
back with more and more and then I was
just like I can't and I didn't do it and
it lasted maybe that series uh only
lasted like five or six episodes got
cancel so so honestly like I'm glad I
didn't do it because it would have been
a canceled series under your belt you
don't want to have too many canceled
series under your belt so like you know
uh so it was good that I didn't do it
but I also was like best case scenario
goes seven years but I'm not going to be
happy I have a lot ton of money but then
I won't there's no there's no way
anybody could be happy doing 10 months a
year for seven years
it's it's unless here's the thing when
you're younger you can do this yeah you
have the ability because your body it's
more you just last you have more time
too because if you're 22 and you get out
of the series at 28 29 you're still
young you still got a career you get in
a series when you're 50 yeah and you
that's it and you're
58 doup is calling you yeah then you
just got to like go retire that's pretty
much maybe that's it I'm getting those
those uh letters now from the a RP a ARP
do you get those yet not yet but I'm
close should I write
back if we can get on the cover together
let's do it you imagine that would be
great let's do a commercial that' be go
hey yeah that' be kind of cool do you um
have you always been one to to learn
your lines quickly do you uh can you
shut it off can you just fall asleep did
you ever did you ever feel anxiety did
you ever get that kind of stuff when you
were working it's pain painful all the
time like like I I wish I had a a
photographic memory me too I do not it
takes me like three days at least to
memorize stuff uh I mean when you're
doing a series your brain starts to pick
it up quicker for sure it definitely
helps and I but if you're like it's it's
like it's a muscle so like between jobs
if you have two months off three months
off and then you have like a chunk of
dialogue like it's stressful to because
it's pressy and and you you want to know
you want now the more you get with my
character the more I feel more
comfortable with my character the more
I'm like okay I can I can make him say
anything and like it's easier to learn
the dialogue when you but when you first
get that you know first day on set and
and you're always like I hope I don't
have like five pages of dialogue it's
just so nerve-wracking because you don't
want to be the one that's like can I say
[__] the Bed Have you ever [__] the
bed
um you know early on in my career I had
a movie that I did and it was a big
movie it was like $60 million I was like
the the main
antagonist working with like name actors
you could say their names right uh yeah
I could say their name I was working
with uh uh Angela Basset wow uh I was
working with Lou Diamond Phillips I was
working with um James sper oh yeah uh
and so like and I was like the main bad
guy in this movie and it was a big
director Walter Hill was
directed and so Warriors yeah Warriors
so uh so I had like the first week off
cuz my character comes in on page like
10 or whatever so they were shooting
like the first week without me and so I
was like you know what I've got this I
know I've got this huge monologue coming
up and I'm gonna crush it so I'm
memorizing this monologue for this you
know the whole time I'm like cramming it
it's like five pages of backstory where
they're like interrogating me and it's
just me talking like it's like and then
what happened and then ch ch ch ch ch
and then and and so this and then ch ch
so I and I knew it backwards and
forwards like that and I was so like
going to CR the night before we shoot no
don't say they change lines on you my my
machine goes starts to go off and I get
a a a notes like hey we rewrote the
scene and it's competely different and
now it's like seven pages of like the
night before the night before Oh gosh
literally the night and it was like 11
o' and I had like I would have said
honestly I'm not doing it I I honestly
just can't do that if you give me an ear
Wick and Fe the [__] lines I'll do it
yeah it was it was terrifying cuz now
I'm like oh God like I so I'm up like
you know I'm looking at it and it's like
not similar it's different you know uh
so I get to set and it was a train wreck
it was like every actor's worst
nightmare like like I still get anxiety
when I think about it because I was like
half in the old monologue and half in
the new one so I would start the new one
and then go in start to go into the old
one then go no and it was so bad that um
I was like I'm going to get fired
there's no way way that I'm not going to
get fired uh so they so Walter was
really cool he was like look he knew I
was struggling so he he put He did all
the other actors coverage first right
and I was still struggling by the end of
the day and uh cuz you're tired now you
really now I'm exhausted and like I've
got again like half of one model and so
uh so at the end of the day um he was
like look I'm not going to shoot your
stuff today just learn it so I I I know
I threw it at your last minute um just
just learn so I went home that night and
I crammed it like cramm it they shot it
the next day they shot it the next day
and you nailed it I nailed it the next
day but but the day of I was like oh I'm
getting fired this my first day oh go
with like huge actors that have been
shooting already for a week so looking
at you like and they're looking at me
like you're [__] the bed and like
and you're like guys I just got this I
just got no one cares nobody cares
nobody cares that happened to me once
where they threw out a scene they go hey
we wrote this scene we added it to
another episode the day of and we're
we're going to shoot it today after
lunch and just my nerves wouldn't let me
memorize the lines I was just already
freaking out and so when I got there it
was just like I remember just doing like
maybe two lines then going line and then
they feed it to me and then I I just do
it but at least you were on a show so
like people knew like hey he could act
like you know imagine being first day on
a huge Studio Movie with like big name
actors and I wasn't a name yet I think
it was like my second movie
and that's the worst thing I've ever and
I'm like oh God this is like you know
all of a sudden you're playing like high
school baseball now you're in the major
leagues and you're tanking you know what
I mean so I was definitely thought I'm
getting fired there's no way I'm not
getting fired I would have rather [__]
my pants in front of those actors I
would have rather [__] my pants in front
of Angela Basset it's pretty much the
same feeling of like uh because they
didn't look at me like oh God I feel
sorry for you they looked at me like
what are you doing here you don't belong
here like I it wasn't and maybe that was
me perceiving it like obviously they
they're not looking at me like that but
I'm looking at it like they're looking
at me like you don't belong here kid
like you're not cutting the mustard and
like we're crushing it what are you do
you know because I just couldn't finish
sentences because I was starting one
sentence going no I starting the next
sentence with an old monologue it was so
confusing to me and it was because I
over prepped and so so now like I don't
really
memorize too early cuz I know that like
what what I don't want that to ever
happen again where it gets cemented
uh so I'll try not to memorize uh until
like a couple of days
out today's sponsor neutr sense.com uses
a CGM right here under my arm which is a
small device that provides real-time
feedback on how your body responds to
the foods that you're eating your
exercise stress and even your sleep now
this is something that look guys if you
see I'm wearing it I wearing my glucose
monitor because I have found out I'm I'm
going to get into this so just give me a
second uh Nutri sense really monitors my
glucose levels so when I find myself
crashing
tired you can just take your phone
because there's an app I put it under my
arm the sensor retrieves all the
information and it shows my glucose
levels for the last x amount of hours
and I go wow I spiked here well that's
cuz you had three root beers dude maybe
you shouldn't be having so much root
maybe you should keep your glucose
levels at a even place so you feel
healthier you feel better you feel have
more energy um you know it's not just
for people who are you know I guess
diabetic or whatever it's for people who
want to live a healthier life and that's
what's happened to me I didn't know what
this was and neutri sense changed my
mind on this whole uh outlook on on on
health um Nutri sense helps you analyze
your glucose levels in real time in
response to food exercise stress and
sleep Nutri sense includes one month of
free board certified nutritionist
guidance and
support uh it really is awesome Ryan if
you want me to get you one um you could
your your life
it's it shows you what you're eating and
and and what you're doing you can
monitor all that you take notes on this
and it's just so easy to say okay okay I
remember I crashed right I was really
tired at 2:00 why well right here it
says well you spiked and you crashed and
this is why this happens and if you're
if you like if you work and you're doing
all these things you need more energy
you monitor your
glucose and it's just amazing my
nutritionist helped me interpret the
data and promptly answered all my
questions Patrick thank you Patrick over
at neutri sense I said well what are
these see how it spikes here and spikes
here well well what exactly are are you
eating and drinking Michael and they you
know we managed it and I said well
what's what are better things I could
have in my diet that I can get some
energy but won't crash and so he sent me
a list of things so it really is
wonderful in in just the short time that
I've done this I've noticed better sleep
I've noticed uh sustained energy less
brain fog it's because I'm not doing
eating all those bad things I'm not
having all that sugar
and it's really helped me and you know
I'm 51 and I no matter how old you are
you want to have sustained energy
throughout the day and right now visit
nutrients.com
inside to save $30 and get one month of
free nutritionist support that's neutr
sense.com
inside inside you is brought to you by
rocket money get the app now I'm going
to tell you why you should get this app
because you're just going to save money
that's it this app is designed so you
and me and Ryan over here we can save
money rocket money is a personal finance
app that findes and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place do you struggle to save
money every month like all of us Ryan
Yes with rocket money you can quickly
identify all those sneaky subscriptions
that keep charging you month after month
and cancel any you no longer use use
it's such an easy way to start saving
money and like 80% of people that have
subscriptions don't even know they have
subscriptions it's it's too easy to
subscribe because sometimes you want to
see a show and this one network Floy or
whatever it is you're like oh I I that's
the only way I could watch this so I
have to subscribe but then you watch the
series and you forget that you still
have it and they're not making $8.99 a
month they've made $80 off you but not
with rocket money they're going to
they're going to take care of that you
know what else is cool is rocket money
can even negotiate to lower your bills
for you by up to 20% all all you have to
do is take a picture of your bill and
Rocket money takes care of the rest it's
pretty fascinating with over 5 million
users in counting rocket money has
helped save its customers an average of
$720 a year and $1 billion in total
savings so far stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
money the Easy Way by going to Rocket
money.com inside that's
rocket.com inside rocket
money.com
inside but do you still think every time
you're about to like it's the day or two
days before the the shoot you're
shooting something do you think oh my
God they're going to change the lines on
me do you still get those haunting
feelings um it's just knowing your lines
has always been nerve-wracking me
because it's like taking a test you and
I don't do good with test yeah I don't
do don't do well on De pression when I
know it and I'm confident I I'm awesome
I love it by day three of filming like
and you know you've already established
like okay I feel like the character
you're getting into a rhythm you know
then you don't there's less pressure on
you you know so like but but when you're
first couple of days and you're working
with new people it's a new day at school
and everyone's looking at
you it's tough like and I think
everyone's trying to find their feet on
the first few days too
So It's just tough for everybody I mean
it's a it's a weird job because we're
always you know it's always changing and
and I love that about it but I also like
you know there's there must be
some having the familiarity of of being
on a series for a while also is is
comforting in some ways too I would I
would think I don't know like like I
said the one that I did do it was more
an ensemble so I was less but even then
like when there was big chunks of
dialogue it's it's a little pressy cuz
cuz you don't have time they don't have
time you know there they're always
racing a clock you know I'll tell you
what was an interesting
experience uh I I just shot a movie I'm
allowed to talk about it on fire which I
just saw yeah and I and I promise you I
watched it yeah I I liked it lot I was
telling you uh you know on the way over
here I thought I wonder if you watched
it CU I was like you know you you talk
to people all the time I wasn't gon to
watch it I was like I don't have time
for this [__] yeah that's what I was
think like like honestly like if I was
meeting people you're doing three or
four of these a day you're like I gota
watch it's almost like homework movies
should be like I want to sit back and
watch a movie have some corn it's harder
to watch movies I find nowadays like
even my own movie like I think it's
because uh there's so much it's well
also it's a time commitment right like
it's a there's so much content out there
but like we're so used to getting things
in short spurts that like you know to
sit down and go okay I'm going to commit
to an hour and a half or two hours is
harder because when you have content on
your phone that's giving you two two
minutes here 2 minutes here and then you
can do something and then 2 minutes
there two minutes and so now like I like
going to the theater cuz like
everything's shut off but but if I'm at
home you're distracted I'll I'll say you
know what I'm going to start this movie
and I'll go but then I have to like
really commit to this for two I don't
have to and now you got kids you got
this you got go back do I want to start
this now and like I know it's harder it
is that's why I have movie Nights on
Tuesday night where we are forced to
watch a movie it's me and my horror
movie Buddies was impressed that you
actually watched it that so so when I
was doing on fire uh the director ended
up getting Co and uh and I ended up
having to take over directing it
unbelievable and uh so you produced it
you co-directed it yeah yeah and stared
it and star in it well I originally was
just going to star in it right you know
they were like hey this this movie do
you want to come out and and I thought
this is a good premise and and you
there's a lot of fires in the world
right now and this is this movie kind of
shows you what people go through you
know and and uh and so I like that
aspect of it and I wasn't a producer on
it either like you until I came on and
then there were things that they were
like hey would you produce it cuz
there's things that we could use your
help on I was like okay and then the
director got sick and then I they were
like hey would you just take over for
tonight and then they were like we can't
shut down we just finish I was like yeah
and then when then it was good cuz when
I was in post and I was able to like
have more say which is always great cuz
as an more fun more creative yeah it's
more creative and and so many times as
an actor I'm sure you know too like we
give over our work and we think oh that
I feel like this is going to be a good
one and then you get disappointed
because uh you don't have any say in
like the the the rhythm of the movie or
how they uh how they put it together or
your performance and you're like I know
I gave them better stuff than that you
know what I mean so like when I saw the
cut you know I was able to say well
let's let's try this or let's these
performances can be better and and you
know get jumped into the editing room
and shaped it and you know the whole
ending we reshot because the original
ending just didn't feel it felt like it
fell flat you know so uh so this ending
that you saw was completely yeah uh
completely reshot and then became more
of a tribute to Firefighters and First
Responders that whole sequence wasn't in
there you know through the woods thing
yeah the kid running uh and that kid had
no you know who played son he didn't
have any Arc so I was like we need an
arc for so I was able to get way more
input into that because I I was now
directing and producing um so it's
called onire it's available on video on
demand digital release film November
14th November 14 so it's going to be
right around here guys so you you got to
check this out because what I and
continue but I just wanted to say that
what I liked about it is that the
characters were all really well thought
out it wasn't like I mean you immed med
care about them you got this old man
your father played by Lance Hendrickson
who I love I've met few just a legend
and like it's not just this you know
angry old guy it's like this emotional
guy who just wants to be with his wife
who passed away and like the some of
those scenes are so emotional he just
wants to smoke and says screw it this is
my life let me just you know let me go
and this whole time you're trying to
hang on to him you're trying to and you
know and the and the and your wife is in
the movie is so F dur she's great great
and she's so strong she's pregnant and
she's the strong character so all the
characters are really strong or
developed and I and I and I saw that and
I liked the even the CGI with the fires
I was like I was looking and it looked
really good yeah cuz when I started that
when I came on when I got this Set uh
Nick Nick lion who who who directed it
alongside with me he started out as the
main director and he when I came on they
were like oh we're not using any fire
you know at all like we're going to do
all CGI and I thought oh this this
better be good or it's going to be bad
yeah yeah yeah uh so so then when we got
into the editing room you know we had
this uh this great um CGI artist uh Joe
Lawson and we just kept pushing him you
know he'd come back with stuff it's
still little keep going back had shapes
shapes of and he did such a great job
like now we have like stock footage
stuff and we have uh CGI stuff I can't
tell the difference sometimes which one
is real and which it's like the smoke
only when you're driving the smoke go in
and out of stuff that was really cool
thank you so so when I took over as
director for that it was interesting
because you know when when I'm an actor
there's a part of me that really wants
to please the director all the time
because you're there to service their
stories so like you know you finish a
take and you're always immediately like
look to them like not of approval do
they like it am I way off like did you
know is it too big too small and uh and
you know you and I have been doing this
for a long time so there's part of us
that knows like what feels right what
doesn't but but you always are looking
straight to that director and catching
their eye and they're like thumbs up and
you know can I try it different like
what else could I do what else do you
think uh and so what was interesting is
I've directed before uh other actors I
love actors I love like working with
them and I love collaborating with them
and I love because they're it's such a
vulnerable place like like you just
mentioned like when knowing your lines
and the pressure so getting actors to go
look you know let's just play you know
and and find stuff together and like I
think that's a pre appreciated and when
I work with directors that are actors
like they understand that that lingo
because sometimes you get directors that
are just like why you making that face
or you're like what fa don't do that
slow down faster yeah faster moving on
yeah and you're just like and it's like
cold bedside manner you know so I think
that actors appreciate when I work with
them because I see everything you know
every little thing an eye movement I'm
like I I saw what you're doing and
actors need to be acknowledged for what
they're doing like sometimes coddled
sometimes they different actors need
different things but sometimes you have
to be that director comes and goes hey
you that was really good I really liked
what you did let's do something else now
cuz we got that it's awesome even if it
was terrible you're like it's good to
tell them it was because then they're
like okay good I got one on T and then
they loosen up like a loose actor is a
good actor I had directors like you just
had go but they know me but they'll be
like Rosen bomb let's do a a better take
than that yeah and like all right what
do you all right gosh you down like if
someone's like making you feel insecure
so you want to make people feel secure
cuz as they're secure and comfortable
they're doing they're giving you more
they're always going to give you more so
so when I work with actors like I I I
love being able to make them feel
comfortable because I want to feel
comfortable when I'm acting you know uh
so but what was interesting about
directing this one when Nick was sick
and and I took over I didn't have that
person to look to to go hey that was
good or bad like it was me you know so
and a and it was so much more freeing in
that sense because I was like okay I
know what I need to get I know what the
scene's
about this show is sponsored by better
help Ryan you ever feel like your brain
is getting in the way of living your
best life all the time yeah I would say
so like you know what you should do
what's good for you but you you just
can't seem to do it oh yeah yeah therapy
helps you figure out what's holding you
back so your brain can work for you
instead of against you and this is what
happens with um therapy you're you have
all these things bottled up and you need
to let them out and you need to talk to
a professional it really really helps
therapy is a great way to learn positive
coping skills and how to set boundaries
it empowers you to be the best version
of yourself and it's way more convenient
with better help it's entirely online
and designed to be convenient flexible
and suited to your schedule just fill
out a brief questionnaire it took me
like a minute in it it's so easy even I
can do it then you get matched with a
licensed therapist switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
seriously it's not uncommon you meet
someone you're like I want to try
someone else it's easy just like that
better help is truly the best way to
make your brain your friend give it a
try visit betterhelp.com
inside today to get 10% off your first
month that's betterhelp
hp.com inside
inside of you is brought to you by
neurohacker this
stuff neurohacker I've been using for
probably five months now and I have just
noticed so much more clarity and
concentration and my memory it just
everything just is
enhanced and it's something I've talked
about like I I didn't know that they
were a sponsor even I just was using
this product and it was working so it
was easy for me to talk about when I
have to talk about it but if you haven't
heard of senolytics it's a class of
ingredients discovered less than 10
years ago and they're being called one
of the biggest discoveries of our time
for helping to promote healthy aging and
helping to enhance your physical prime
your life goals in your career and
Beyond require productivity but let's be
honest the aging process is not our
friend when it comes to endless energy
and productivity especially when you hit
my age 51 uh that's why I use qua
senolytic as we age everyone accumulates
Cent cells in their body and what makes
the quala brand unique is fully
transparent formulas no proprietary
ingredients formulas created by top
scientists MDS and NDS science-backed
formulas backed with hundreds of
research citations powerful results
thousands of real life-changing reviews
over 6 years in counting just read the
website 100 day money back guarantee
zero Financial Risk to try any qua
formula Sen ENT cells may cause symptoms
of Aging such as aches and pain slow
workout recoveries sluggish mental and
physical energy associated with that
middle-age feeling also known as zombie
cells they are old and worn out and not
serving a useful function for our health
anymore but they could be taking up
space and nutrients from our healthy
cells much like pruning the yellowing
and Dead Leaves off a plant qualia
senolytic helps remove those worn out
Cent cells to allow for the rest of them
to thrive in the body and it just you
just need to take it 2 days a month it's
so easy it's non-GMO vegan gluten-free
and the ingredients are meant to
complement one another factoring the
combined effect of all ingredients
together and a 100 day money back
guarantee so I don't know what you're
you're you got to do this it's uh
whenever anybody offers a 100 day money
back guarantee they probably believe in
their product help resist aging at the
cellular level try qualia senolytic go
to neurohacker / inside for up to $100
off and use code inside at checkout for
an additional 15% off these statements
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration the products and
statements are not intended to diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease that's
neurohacker dcom inside for an extra 15%
off your purchase thanks to neurohacker
for sponsoring today's
episode you don't worry about you as
much and I'm not worried about me yeah I
did the same thing and then it became
more about like I need to give to the
other actors because I need them to be
good for this so I came I became such
like so much more of a giving actor
because was it wasn't about like Serv
how was I doing it was about like I have
to give as much as I can to get that
other actor to give me more and so it
became about giving all the time yeah
and I'm like I want to take that into my
next stuff like yeah but I I'll say that
uh I remember when I was doing directing
this film and I was the lead in it and
the the editor called me up after and he
goes hey bud I go hey how's it going
he's like uh was something wrong did you
see the dailies he go yeah nothing's
wrong but uh you're the lead role you
need to give yourself more takes and I'm
like why am I not good he's like no it's
not that it's just like I want you to I
know how you are you want to give to
everybody else but remember you need to
give yourself the options and things in
the editing room I go all right and so
did you think about that at all or did
someone say that to you like no but but
I had directed a movie before this one
that I wrote and directed and I did that
on that because I I played a smaller
role in that one and and and yeah
because when you're I I I mean exhaust
it I almost died no one knows that but I
felt like it I played a smaller role in
that one cuz I didn't I wanted to be
able to get you know focus on directing
but but when I did have to come in to
work cuz I was like I'll I'll play this
smaller role so it's fun you know
everyone else is going to be having fun
the smaller Ro but it was like a pain in
the ass cuz it was like I got to put my
costume on I got to hair and makeup I
want to be by the crew in the set
setting up the camera and now I'm
sitting hair and makeup like dying
because I want to be onet and then I get
there and it and became like that like
okay let me just race through my stuff
because I got to get to their coverage I
gotta get to and I got and so I learned
on that one not that I was bad in that I
don't think I was bad uh but it was like
I I I learned in that one like okay I I
have to also give myself options but
having I have a I had a good producer
friend of mine on on on fire too and he
also directs so I would look at him he
had your back he had my back and I would
look at him and go hey that cool yeah
and it wasn't in the way of like was
that good do you want something else it
was just it was just a confirmation like
that felt good to me you know my best
friend Tom who's not an actor not in the
business he he would be off camera and
he'd got go do one more yeah that's all
I need you kind of need that otherwise
you're running to the monitors
watching I never watched the scene with
me in it I never let them go back roll
back yeah cuz you just don't have the
time to sit there I mean you're
literally racing a clock it's literally
a race every day but I I I love the rush
love the race I actually really enjoy
directing I think I've always been I
think I've been a more frustrated I
think I've always been a frustrated
director who who acted cuz like I I mean
even when I was acting it was always
like I feel like that this should be
shaped differently or like I wish you
would put the camera over there like and
I'd have all these ideas and I was like
you have to be careful because you never
want to like you know step on director's
toes um but but I'd always be like what
would happen if you did that thing and
then sometimes they'd be like oh yeah
I'm gonna steal that yeah there's a way
to do it got be a good like you know
because uh pal and Terry uh Chaz pal and
Terry I did this movie with him it was a
first-time director and he goes what are
we doing and the director would say say
I'm going to move the camera over here
and I'm going to get this cool shot it's
going to go like it's going to move
through here and go through here goes
all right you'll never use it but do
what
you that's what he would say to him and
like um but yeah it it is it is it's a
delicate balance you have to really be
respectful because and I'm all overly
respectful with directors because it's
like I never would want somebody telling
me but I'm the type of guy that's like
look I'll take a good idea from anyway
craft service guy's like hey would you
try this and it works I'd be like I
always say that too if you have a good
idea I'll do it just don't bombard me
with things don't feel like now it's
this open door policy but by the way I
will say one more thing about um on fire
which you guys got to see November 14th
on video demand and digital release can
we just talk about Jacob for a second
yeah the character Jacob small character
that you meet with like when you're on
your way to save I'm not going to give
anything away but you know save someone
and this random guy who
so emotional in in the midst of this
fire and his performance and just like
both of you guys together I thought that
was some of one of the best scenes in
the movie oh thank you man CU I really I
directed that night and uh and I was
really excited to work with that actor
because he was he brought a lot of stuff
and I was like oh my God he so emotional
yeah and at first it it wasn't like it
was kind of like safe and I was like try
this try and then it got to that and
then and it was one of those nights that
you felt like okay I really helped shape
that and make him comfortable enough so
because a lot of times you know if he
came with that he might have thought oh
well is this too B but but but giving
him the space to actually work in that
and then get them there and I I really
like that scene too in the original cut
it was it wasn't in it and I was like no
we need to put that back in because it's
a scene where I meet this guy on the
road and I'm not giving too much away
but but uh he he ends up coming out of
the woods and and I'm and I and I'm
driving to to find my family and he
needs a ride back you know home cuz his
you know uh house just burned down he's
very emotional and uh and and I'm like
okay I just have to go and get my family
and then we'll go back to town and he
turns from like help me to no to helping
me instead of asking for help he's
actually giving me help and he's going
no no you can't go that way because
you're going to die and I'm like I have
to go that way and it becomes almost
like an argument he's like you're not
listening to me you can't go that way
cuz he's seen what's in the abyss right
yeah he's like you you you can't go
there you got
it's so traumatic and and then it makes
my character like like you root for him
because now he's doing something heroic
where he knows oh my God wherever I'm
going it's going to be bad but I I'm
going anyway and he sees it in your eyes
you didn't have to even say much you
just like said I have to do this and he
looks at you go and he says I'll what's
your name yeah he says I'll pray for you
and it's like all of a sudden it it
comes from a place of like please help
me my house burned down to oh my God
you're you're screwed you're GNA die
you're gonna die I'm gonna pray for you
and then the the T the the tables get
turned and it wasn't really written that
way like like we got it there uh you
know what that was that was Humanity
like how Humanity should be that's what
it should be like you know people
helping each other yeah and it was just
and you can see the trauma that he went
through you know what I mean just by the
his his the way he was playing that
scene it was like such a traumatic event
he was just coming from and knowing that
I was going to go into that traumatic
event he was trying to like stop me but
my family was in there so I have to keep
going you know and then it's like we're
only like 10 15 minutes in and you're
already as an audience member going okay
this guy's you know doing something
heroic I'm going to follow him my my
character because he's like putting his
life on the line to to anyways you know
what I mean hey when was the first time
like your parents said our sons made it
now I feel comfortable and saying our
son's doing it he's he's he's made it
like when was you know cuz your parents
were probably you know your dad was a
waiter yeah wait and your mom was a just
a homemaker like and and so when you
wanted to be an actor was it something
so foreign to them they're like what are
what are you doing yeah I mean I I kind
of had to trick them into it cuz like I
when I was younger I was like I was
really shy when I was younger like super
shy like so shy that in
High School I was too shy to get in on
the lunch line cuz I was like well what
if like I drop my tray or what if like
something happens I the whole cafeteria
you know in those movies where something
happens the whole you got a rip in your
pants the whole cafeteria is looking at
you I would I would die right and I went
to school with like 3,500 kids like
there was a lot so it was intimidating
to like grab your tray get on a lunch
line giant jocks next to you and like
and uh and so for the first three years
I I like ate a pretzel in the back of
the room room and got grabbed an orange
like there was a little lady that on the
opposite side sold pretzels and while
everybody was getting hamburgers and
pizza I went to the the lady grabbed the
pretzel and an orange juice and sat down
and like it was like a Wallflower you so
it wasn't like I was like a theater kid
that was like look at me I you know and
and no confidence well yeah and I wasn't
theatrical I didn't never did a play so
I remember tell my parents cuz I saw
Butch Cassie a Sundance Kid and I was
like those guys look like they're having
fun you know I want to do that because
when you're 12 you're like you don't
know what you're like oh I could do that
that looks like fun so I told my parents
I was like yeah I want to be an actor
and they laughed because they're like
this shy kid and you know um also
they're from Italy and I'm first
generation American so like they don't
we don't we knew nobody in the business
like movies were foreign to us like my
dad uh I think he took me to one movie
in my my whole life like my the first
movie he took me to was uh he wanted was
funny it was Indiana Jones came out I
think I was like 10 and he was like oh
don't take this movie Indiana Jones and
I didn't know what it was because it
said Indiana Jones and the Temple of
Doom but it sounded like Raiders a lost
Arc it was great Raiders a lost Arc
right and it's I thought it was like a
movie about the Bible about you because
it was like the Arc of the Covenant and
I was like I don't want to see this a
religious movie so I cried and was like
I want to see Annie so my dad took me to
see Annie and he fell asleep and I
watched Little Orphan Annie and that was
like the first movie ever watch I was
like 10 cu I didn't go to the movies you
know yeah um so so telling them I want
to be an actor was like uh tell them I
want to go to Mars it was just like not
a thing that was possible so they
laughed and I didn't want to be laughed
at so next time they said what do you
want to be I said a lawyer and they were
like oh a lawyer in the family my son's
going to be a lawyer you know uh so so
then I kind of convinced myself that's
what I would be you know and and uh I
went to to all through high school and
didn't do a play in high school school
ever uh and then I went to college and I
and I went to one year uh at St John's
University and I studied pre-law you
know uh and and then I I I took like an
acting 101 class and I really liked it I
was like Wow because I was so shy it was
freeing for me because when I was
playing other characters like people
don't see me they see these other people
I could do anything as a as a character
right uh it's always that acting 101
yeah get you
going inside of you is brought to you by
discover if you like using debit over
credit don't you think it's time you
also get rewarded well now you can with
discover cashback debit it's a checking
account that rewards everyone with cash
back on everyday purchases plus there
are no fees period we're talking date
nights thrifting the latest trends
nights out with your friends and it's
now earning you cash back with discover
cashback debit check out eligibility and
terms at discover.com
slashback deit Discover Bank member
FDIC and uh and so then I met this guy
and he was like a
manager and I and I was trying to get
into like modeling a little bit and uh I
was doing like little things here and
there it wasn't like you know just to
for to pick up money on the side and
then and then he said if you want to be
an actor you should really study it and
so he helped me transfer into NYU to
study theater there and so I told my
parents hey I'm going to I'm going to
transfer it to NYU and I actually
auditioned and I got in to the theater
program there and they they said what
why are you studying acting I don't
understand and this school's like twice
as much as your other school yeah I said
Well it has a you know as a as a as a
lawyer you have to stand up in front of
people I'm really shy and acting is
required to be a lawyer you're lying to
them yeah I totally lied totally playing
them I see what you're doing I said you
know you have to stand up in front of
people and it's like doing a PL you have
to take acting class it'll help me be a
better lawyer and they didn't know so
the the good thing about my parents was
there's there's parents that like if
their kid like shits in a box they're
like look what my kid made you know and
my and then there's the other parents
that are just like uh on the other side
like my parents like my mom never came
to a baseball game you know my dad took
me to like one movie my whole life like
they just did their thing and I did mine
thing and in some ways like it was good
because they kind of stayed out of like
I I I actually had a conversation with
my mom the other day I said cuz I had a
motorcycle at 19 I was like did you guys
like me like I would never let my my son
did you like me get a motorcycle at 19
she was like oh no that's what you
wanted to do I I mean I I thought you
were crazy but I was like you know
that's what it was like they just didn't
they were they let me be me which was
really kind of wonderful but they loved
you and they gave you all that stuff and
they loved me and and it wasn't like see
that's why it worked they gave you the
love and everything it was like they
were ignoring and abandoning me they
just weren't on top of you they just
weren't on top of me they weren't
helicopter parents so like when I said I
was going into NYU they were just like
okay you know I got a baseball game this
weekend okay you like I'm coming home
tonight I'm going out okay you come
don't come home late okay you know like
they didn't jeez I wish that was my they
didn't really helicopter paring me they
get your ass home the [__] out of so so
they were loose in that sense but in the
sense of like hey I really think you can
make it as an actor they weren't that
either but they never said you can't
make it as an they just were like he's
going NYU he's taking AC I don't know
you know they just so then so I took I
went to NYU and I studied acting and
then and then I ended up getting um an
episode like a guest starring episode or
something and I was like hey I'm going
to be on this guest and I had like the
lead G uh like guest um you know episode
lead what are they call lead lead guest
lead you know I the lead is that what
they called guest lead guest lead I
don't know the lead actor in the guest
guest leap Opera it was a I can't say
the show but it was a it was a show that
dealt with uh law and it also dealt with
other stuff like or order like like
order and and and there was also like
criminal law criminal stuff and judge
stuff gotcha got and stuff like and so
um so I did a show that was my first
answer due to the sex strike Peter
fanelli can't say the word beep yeah so
uh it dealt with like judges and and law
and so I ended up being the lead a guest
leader on that show and and I said I'm
going to be on this series and so my
parents watching and they thought I was
going to be like the guy just kind of
like oh that's my hand you see it you
know the guy just walked through the
door and the back Blown Away no they
weren't they were they were surprised
but I never got the I actually never got
the oh my God that was amazing I can't
believe you did did that either they
were just but they weren't like I think
they were just a little show great you
got that's great they were just like oh
that's cool and they really didn't think
anything of I mean
honestly for the first 20 years of my
career my dad would be like listen if
you uh if you ever need it your room
well we still have a room for you like
like so I never got I always got the
same thing I never got the uh you know I
think you finally made it you know I
feel like they're proud of me but after
you did a movie with a bunch of
vampires no I think that they come on no
because here's the thing my they don't
understand the world of it so when I go
home you know my moms were interested in
like why aren't you eating you know I
mean eat your pasta like you're getting
too skinny eat this like so it's like
the the blessing of my parents are they
would love me no matter what I did you
know what I mean the fact that they they
only care don't make me cry now they
only care if I'm happy that like my mom
says like if if if something's really
successful she are you happy then I'm
happy too she doesn't care if it's
successful as long as I'm
happy they're happy which is really did
they ask you that did they ask you they
are you happy are you good yeah like
I'll be like hey I got this movie are
good are you happy yeah like good you
know but they're not they're not
enamored they're not they're not
enamored at they're not like it's just
like they want you to be happy and if
that makes you happy that makes them
happy I think the biggest uh compliment
I got was actually recently cuz my my
parents went to see on fire in the movie
theater you know which is nice we had
great run we like 500 theaters for a
small movie is is a wonderful uh you
know run and so my dad and mom went to
see it in the middle of the day and my
dad called me after I said what do you
think he goes oh it was great you're
better than Richard Gear I was like okay
W because he doesn't know anybody my dad
so like he'll always throw out
references like uh you know um John
Wayne that's an actor I'm like I can't
work like I can never impress them
because I'm like I can't work with John
Wayne he's dead you know so I remember
calling my my dad once I said hey I'm
working with um I'm working with Danny
DeVito and he goes oh was that the guy
in my cousin Vinnie and I was like no
that's Joe peshy and then guy I was like
uh I called my my parents like said I'm
working with Drew Barrymore and and they
go oh is he
nice your grandfather great-grandfather
Barrymore I don't know so they just
don't know anybody or so they're not
they're not impressed well the same
thing happened to me I was at um the
Elizabeth Glazer AIDS Foundation event
one year and I took my grandparents with
me
and I see George Lucas H and he looks at
me and goes and I'm like
uh come here points at me W and I go
guys George
Lucas is asking me to come over and talk
to him she he my grandfather goes who's
that let's go talk to the guy from
cheers Ted Dan's right over there like
it's [__] George Lucas they didn't
know who he was and he invited me to the
ranch and all that stuff they just you
know they but you know what's great is
and I'll sort of elaborate what you said
my grandparents my I have letters from
my grandfather that would say Michael
Mikey we just want to say how proud We
Are of you and even if you didn't do any
of this you're a good man you're a good
boy love you and like that meant more to
me than anybody ever saying you were
great in the film or you were in this or
just hearing my grandparents just say
they love me I think it's a different I
don't know where your grandparents from
but it's a different generation and like
they're proud of me when they hear like
I remember they my parent I took my
parents to a I was doing that series I
did for like seven years and the
showrunners said to them your son's a
really hard worker and that stuck with
my dad like he's like you know when they
said you were a hard worker that made me
really proud like like the show could
come and do well and like tons of people
it's like the fact that somebody said I
was a hard worker that made him proud of
you know I think my uh I think my
father uh for a long time until I
finally just stood up to him one day but
he he would say I think I think he felt
like acting in this industry was a
breeze and just it was cupcakes and
people give you whatever you want you
don't do anything and you don't work
hard and you don't and all he did was
work hard so I think he just didn't
where did you guys grow up uh I was born
in New York but I grew up in Indiana
Indiana but and was your dad like a blue
collar yeah like just worked his ass off
and I think he just didn't respect me
and didn't anything and then one day I
was like I you have no idea anything
about anything I [__] do you don't
know how hard I work you don't know how
hard it is you know how much rejection
we face you don't know anything you
assume it's just and I just stood up to
him you know I just said that it was
just it wasn't easy but it was like it
was just you're right it's that old
school mentality like he wants to know
that you work you work hard for a living
you don't just you don't just you know
well you memorize those monologues you
and and the pressure you're under and
the stuff we talked about earlier like a
12h hour day you know how about just
love your [__] kids how about just
unconditionally I don't care Ryan what
you do Peter whatever you do as long as
you're happy like you said hon my my
mom's always been like that like is
whatever I if I worked at the drive-thru
it make Donald's my mom would be would
treat me exactly the same and sometimes
I want the mom that's like my son [__]
in this box look what he made I mean
seriously but I know I'm not going to
get that so it's but I I kind of I I I
think the a lot of part of my career was
always like I'm going to get them to be
like look you know look what he made and
then I never really got that so I I let
that go I let it go too I let it go
because it became like you know what
they don't care but not because they
don't care it's because they care more
about me being happy yeah not about
succcess success for them is are you
happy because and it's true like a lot
of and I I'm like that with my kids now
like I don't care what they do as long
as they're happy that's kind of like My
Philosophy with them you know that's a
beautiful thing it's like uh you know um
you're a product of your environment own
environment and it's like if you had a
good upbringing and your parents loved
you you that's easier to translate right
it's it's hard to go against the gr it's
it's it's
shockingly it's it's tougher I think to
have bad parents and then be a good
parent it's probably easier to have good
parents and also you're a good parent
yeah so you have to either break the
cycle or it helps it helps you yeah so
it's uh it's crazy it's but it's it's
amazing how I see some of my friends
grow up and the support that they had
and the love that they had and and even
if they had no money and they weren't
well educated
the love that was there was
just it resonated with me as a little
boy looking at other familyes going you
know what she really loves my friend she
really loves her
son I and I remember that and I remember
when she tear up when he was going away
from college and I remember like certain
things that I was like oh I didn't I
didn't necessarily get that but I I
could see it and that's important yeah
you know what I mean so anyway sometimes
it comes back to me either sometimes I
talk about me and no I mean I think
that's I think that's it's great when
you have that you could see that in
other people and even in this
conversation when you're like I could
see the love of my parents through how
Peter's parents you know treat them too
because it's like it's a different love
it's not the I'm going to show up at
every baseball game it's like hey did
were you did you enjoy yourself today
you know what I mean yeah and that's
that's a good love too and yeah no I
think it's important I think it just is
just important to just be like I love
you whatever you do I'm going to love
you MH don't always try to get my
approval just do things because you love
them do things because they give you
purpose do things because you know they
make you happy or whatever it is you
have a passion for it it's like you know
it's uh but I think why I don't have
kids you're like why don't you have kids
I'm like well I'm 51 you're like so what
I'll be I'm 49 I I got another kid on
the way yeah Pino and the way you have a
oneye old Oney old but Pino and dairo
just had kids there yeah but come on I
think there's something wrong with that
I mean you may not but I'm like I think
as a as listen as a how old is he bino I
don't know 70 76 think about it when the
kid's 10 he doesn't have a
dad well 20 I mean you you can enjoy him
for as long as you enjoy him I guess
like whatever makes people happy yeah
you're right you're right but I do think
like you could be an older I was on both
ends of the spectrum where I was the
youngest dad I mean I had kids at
21 was my first kid I was literally like
the youngest dad in the kindergarten
class you know uh and then and see you
have a 27y old yeah yeah good Lord
Almighty and then I have uh you know now
I have a one-year-old so it's kind I'm
starting over but it's and and so now
I'm like on the older end of that
Spectrum you know uh and most of the
dads are in their 30s and 40s and like
all right uh but I do feel like and in a
lot of ways kids keep you young cuz like
you you have to have the energy for them
but like they light their smile lights
up a room and then all of a sudden it's
like doesn't matter how your day was you
know over to him he does a smile or does
something goofy you know you're right
does but when you find somebody that you
want to have kids with and like I
wouldn't put an age limit on it honestly
like you know what I mean uh if you're
in a place where you you can you're with
with somebody that you love and and uh
and you you you you want to have a kid
don't be like I'm too old like I I don't
I don't think I don't think that's I
would do it if I could be an
stay-at-home dad and the my wife
works what if you could do another uh
movie that you've done like a a another
uh what's the word a sequel or a show to
go back and you know how people are
always revisiting these things you can't
say the name but you could kind of you
know we could figure it out but would
there be a movie that you would be like
I'd revisit that they've got a cool idea
with it like would you re visit uh the
one about the uh you know uh EO Edy
Falco yeah 100% like there's I think all
of the the roles I've done if they were
ever like would you want to revisit
there's not one role I've done where I'm
like I never want to play that again you
know what I mean not not one and I think
the I've always had this lipus test and
it served me well when I take on a rooll
I always think to myself am I going to
be excited on my ride to work and that's
the litest I have have for like saying
yes to I say the same element of fun
yeah because because if I have the
passion on the way to work and I'm
excited on the way to work I know I'm
going to put everything I have into it
and then I can't control if the movie
does well the TV show does well but but
when I look back and someone's like what
was your favorite thing you've ever done
I can honestly say all of them because
I've had the same level of passion on
the ride to work for each and every one
of them so if someone's like hey would
you would you want to revisit that role
yeah cuz I had fun doing it you know
what I mean even if it was like I've
done one that's for seven years like I
had honestly had fun going to work every
day even the Vampire movie yeah you do
it in a heartbeat in a heartbeat I mean
I'm probably too old to play now because
like vampires don't age but uh you can
age if you want to can you n vampire if
you don't drink enough blood and you get
older and then you drink blood no I
think I they change the [__] they could
I think they could I think you look good
oh thank you man it's all in the eyes
hey this is called [__] talking with
Peter fanell this is my these are my
patrons this is just rapid fire uh and
you can answer them these patreon.com
inside you I couldn't do this show
without you thanks for supporting the
podcast Leanne how has being a a father
made you a better
person um it gives me a lot more
patience because now when I when I look
at people often times when I'm like you
know somebody cuts you off or somebody
you know rubs the wrong way I think of
them and think they were a child once
too and you know what I mean so like I
have more compassion for people because
I could see their inner child because my
kids have good days like my one-year-old
he has great days he has bad days you
know and so having the patience for him
I I I try to bring that into having the
patience with a more adult so if someone
cuts you off you don't get pissed off I
I don't I mean it to a fa cuz wow
because here's here's the thing like and
it's a wonderful thing cuz when but your
part Italian what the [__] are you doing
no because when you don't react to them
then they it's almost comical cuz
they're like they get mad they get more
and they're waving their hands around
sometimes I'll wave and smile like you
know what I mean and it and I don't mean
to piss him off more but it's like you
know if you don't get sucked into
somebody else's energy there's a great
quote if I try to give you a gift and
you don't take it who does it belong
to it falls back on me right so
someone's trying to throw their energy
of negativity onto you and you don't
take it it just goes back to them it
just falls back on them words of wisdom
passion little Lisa what has been your
biggest challenge this year and what has
been your biggest accomplishment this
year W the biggest uh accomplishment was
you know working really hard on on fire
to like get it to a place where it got
into 500 theaters and like you know uh
dedicated to all the survivors and
firefighters to make yeah to help shape
that movie into something that people
are enjoying and uh and and then being
able to you know Pro promote it with
sag's uh not only approval but them
cheering us on because we signed the
interm agreement we we I was able to
work with the producers to have them
agree to pretty much everything we're
asking the studios for so you know sag
is actually using us as an example hey
if if if these smaller producers can
sign us agement than the bigger Studios
should too so like it feels good to be
part of uh like part of me is like this
this movie I did was the first movie in
theaters under the Sagen arum agreement
and that to me is like a wonderful
feeling because I'm helping to like my
union you know what I mean yeah uh to to
to to help them in their their their
battle and I talk to them all the time
like what else can I do because I really
do believe in what we're fighting for uh
but the struggling in that sense this
year has been you know because of the
strike it's it's been tough because I
love being creative and uh and there's
less creativity to be had or to work
with or to you know jobs to do like so
so then I end up getting um it's almost
feels like Co again where I'm at home
going what can I
do uh to like get my creative juices
flowing and that's a challenge to like
you know when you're on set it's it's
easier when somebody's like this is
where you have to be this is what we're
doing this is your lunch and this is the
end of the day and these are the lines
that you have to learn and there's
structure in that and I find it harder
when I don't have that structure to
structure it for myself you know I mean
and so a day could go by and it's just
like I didn't do anything today I was
like stuck I got sucked into like my
Instagram stories and you know and and
it's just other things I want to be
doing and then you kind of procrastinate
and like so so the challenge has been
trying
to uh work that structure in for myself
I like it I like it Bob K Elvis or The
Beatles wow I gotta say Elvis because I
have an Elvis pinball machine at home
and he's the king but I do like Bob and
the Beatles too you like Bob who asked
the question I no I thought you meant
Bob Dylan oh no Bob asked Elis in the
Beatles he's like I like Bob too I
thought you me oh n will like that you
like Bob I do like Bob I do like Bob I
spit I thought you said Bob or Elvis or
The Beatles uh that as in Bob Dylan um
Bob Dylan Beatles but but Elvis would
have to be my i' Elvis for sure uh Le
and Kristen say if you could forget a
book or a movie and be able to
experience it for the first time again
what would you
choose book or a movie a book or a movie
that's a t I would say would I get the
same feeling as when I first saw it
because that like if I Saw The Shining
for the first time now and felt the same
scare that I did back then I'd say The
Shining or um Star Wars Star Wars or
Empire Strikes Back I mean the the cool
thing about Star Wars is now when you
get the new Star Wars you get to have
that feeling of like oh it feels like
the first time watching and then you
know uh because because there's new
stories to be told but but I would go
with Star Wars the first one yeah yeah
jam and Jenny what's your favorite way
to relax or unwind after a stressful
day
um uh smoke some of the reefer do you I
mean I don't I this is terrible but let
me think uh to unwind is sex sex I my my
mind went to like sex man if that's what
it is why not if you have sex it relaxes
you Rel sex puts me to sleep is it that
see it's relaxing I me not during yeah
but like but that's relaxing no
absolutely there's nothing more relaxing
than having uh uh what rhymes with for
gasm but then you just immediately for
guys at least just
like it's it just shuts you down well if
you're having a stressful day too it
like takes you out of the stressful day
because you're in the moment of doing
something that is feeling good and and
also con connection and uh you know and
and a sharing of love and then and then
at the end it's very relaxing I mean is
that terrible to say No in fact I may
not even have that for the patrons I may
do that for a question so more people
could hear it why not we would you to
relax I like to have sex why is that
weird yeah that weird Dana asks what's
the weirdest GI gift you gotten from a
fan oh what's the weirdest gift I don't
know if it was a gift but I had a fan
once s will you sign my knickers and I
didn't know what knickers were so I was
like ah sure and then she like gave me
some underwear and I was like oh I can't
sign that that's that's not that's just
too weird that's too weird I had someone
asked if I if she if I'd signed their
breast and I did no I didn't it was a
side breast so I think I did
that um look you've done so much we
didn't even crack the surface on so many
things but you guys have known all the
things he's done you can look him up he
got this movie on fire which I sat down
and watched really enjoyed it's it's an
important movie it's intense it's
emotional it's also got some comedy to
it I think there's some funny little
nuances in there that really made me
laugh out loud Lance especially Lance
great it was really cool the characters
are well developed it's on fire November
14th video on demand or digital release
um this has been an honor man thanks man
you I had a really good time with the
weird thing is you you and I have been
around for a long time and we've never
really crossed I don't think and I
always liked you I always liked you me
too I've never really I don't think
we've ever been like at an event at the
same no correct me if I'm wrong nope
it's like I I I thought to myself I've
never met Peter but I always loved your
work I swear it was I know of you and I
know who you are and I know your work
and and I've felt the same respect and
and and same like oh that's a cool guy
and I know we have friends that are I
think know each other too I'm sure of it
so so it was through that do you know no
I'm kidding such a pleasure to actually
sit down and chat with you really
enjoyed you too man thanks for being
here thanks for taking the time good
luck on the movie on fire thank
you solid solid guy I
uh again you know when you watch someone
act throughout the years and you're like
oh he's got this Persona I wonder how he
is is he serious is he and uh he just
came across so humble and sweet and uh
it was really nice to see just a good
dude it's nice when the the business
doesn't get you you can't let the
business get you oh that old business
that old entertainment industry
business it can get you oh yeah um but I
appreciate you for being on the podcast
and good luck with the movie I know it's
going to do well it's uh it's really
good and uh thank you Peter so you guys
could also uh write a review if you want
you could watch on YouTube or anywhere
else
well you can just watch on YouTube but
uh I guess what we should do right now
is the um top tier patrons we should I
think we should thank you guys so much
for listening it means the world to me
again patron.com inside of you you can
get your name shouted out uh top tiers
and other tiers get certain things like
boxes from me and little notes from me
and uh occasional zooms and just there's
all sorts of stuff I even think that top
tiers might be two tiers from top top
tier but they get uh you know we get get
a bonus episode with me and Ryan they
get like what else do they get they get
uh [__] talking questions [__] talking
is now I think a patron exclusive so
those are questions just from patrons so
patreon.com insidey let's read out the
top tier patrons Ryan you have them in
front of you I
do all right Nancy D Leen
Kristen little Lisa
Yukiko uh Julie Brian h niiko p Robert B
Jason w sopie m r C Joshua D Jennifer N
wow that was fast I I was feeling it
coffee kicked in Stacy L Jamal F Janelle
B I just saw you Janelle just saw a lot
of you so wonderful to see Mike E Elon
Supremo 99 Mo San Diego M Chad W lean p
matd espinda and Dave Hall look it's
Dave Hall I love Dave Hall he's my
favorite Dave I miss you Dave
Hall Sheila G Brad d Ray H tap with the
T Tom n t m ET D ran and C Cory K Dev
Nexon Michelle a Jeremy C Brandy D Joy M
and you saved Eugene and Lee I just saw
you guys at the con too what a treat and
I got to see the little one he's so cute
he was he was good he wasn't crying guys
Eugene and Leah are such good parents
Corey Angela F Mel s Christine s Eric H
Shane R Andrew M Amanda R Kevin e
Stephanie K Jor
L jamond J lean J Luna R Mike F Stone H
Kayla uh parenthetical stay wild
moonchild yes and parenthesis Brian L
Kendall L Cara oh is it Cara or K I
think it's kery ker kerosene kerosene
Jessica B Kyle F and Marisol P Marisol
you weren't at the last few cons Marisol
what the hell
marisel uh Kaylee J hi Brian a Ashley F
Maran Louise L Romeo B Frank B Jen T
Nikki L April R Randy s jdw oral P
Ginger Insomniac Rachel d laurelai l hi
laurelai hi Melissa H Nick W Stephanie
and Evan Charlene a and Don G I couldn't
do this podcast without you you know
that thank you from the bottom of my
fraking heart and uh for my Michael Ros
mom here in the Hollywood Hills of
California I'm Ryan TZ I'm also here
you're here hey little way to the camera
guys thank you be good to yourself I'll
see you
later